welcome back humana the sponsors of this
next segment partnered up with cano
health to provide extra care for the
community i spoke to both to learn more
rachel of humana dr aguilar of kennel
welcome to the show
so glad to be here thank you rocky yes
hi brockery i'm thrilled to be here
thanks so much for the opportunity
absolutely absolutely so dr aguilar this
question is for you um you guys are
bringing in a new primary care center to
las vegas tell us about that
well rocky i'm so excited to be talking
to you about it today like you said
regular visits to your primary care
office is incredibly important for
maintaining your health and preventing
problems especially as we age
according to recent stanford study
actually access to your primary care
provider was associated with a longer
lifespan for populations so really
excited to be opening up a brand new
primary care center right here in las
vegas specifically focus on serving the
medicare population and canada is really
proud to be helping increase access to
our community
absolutely and thank you guys for
joining forces here and bringing such
help to our community rachel is there
anything else you want to add about the
new primary care center
uh yes at humana our work with kano
health and other providers in our
network is an important part of our
commitment to improving population
health in the communities we serve and
offering compassionate integrated care
to our medicare advantage members by
working with providers who share our
focus and who are opening centers like
the one here in las vegas we hope to
increase the quality of and access to
care for our medicare advantage members
and who's invited to this primary care
center so we open up the invitation for
all the community members just to come
take a look at the beautiful facility
the great uh clinicians that we have to
to have access to a friendly comfortable
environment so people from the community
but specifically those elderly in the
medicare population to access the great
services we provide for them absolutely
and rachel how can people get more
information about the primary care
center and about what you guys are doing
for us
well if you're interested in learning
more about humana plans we encourage you
to call a licensed sales associate at
eight 1-800-345-8000 one seven monday
through friday 8 a.m to 8 p.m you can
also visit health thatcares.com to learn
more
okay well thank you so much rachel dr
aguilar we appreciate you in everything
you're doing for our community
especially for our elderly so thank you
so much rocky
thank you humana for sponsoring that
segment for more information you can
call 1-800-345-8017
monday through friday 8 a.m to 8 p.m or
just visit health.cares.com